Marques: Sega successfully
positioned themselves
as the sophisticated
alternative to Nintendo.
But 30 years later,
the question of which console
is better still persists.
So, today we're gonna do
our own tests
to determine a winner.
This is Console Wars.
( music playing )
All right,
so to jump right into it,
we have our debaters
Dave and Joe
representing
Sega and Super Nintendo.
So these are the categories
we're testing today.
Gaming and Graphics,
Sound Chip,
and the Mascot.
So, Dave, I'll start.
Gaming and Graphics.
( music playing )
This is Sonic 1.
Blast processing is
how we're able to get
all these moving images
and tons of things
on the screen
in quick succession
without things slowing down.
So we'll see that if you,
like, lose all your coins
and they're all on the screen
- at the same time like that?
- Yeah, like that.
Did you see that slowdown
right there?
Did you see that slowdown?
I don't know
what you're talking about.
They can't handle all
of the sprites on screen.
- And look at that 3-D ring.
- Oh, wow.
Joe: That ring moving
at three frames a second.
Three frames is
all you need, baby.
All right, so now it's time
to see the graphics
from Super Nintendo.
If anybody is standing,
please sit.
You're about to be blown away.
So, I brought
Donkey Kong Country.
Look at these
beautiful 3-D vistas that
we're seeing right here.
Yes, I don't need to go
a thousand miles an hour.
Look at these rendered
3-D characters.
Look at that high-five.
Look at the frame rate of that.
What a beautiful fall
that was.
( music playing )
So, I brought
some evidence on my iPad.
I have some various sounds
associated with each
of these two consoles.
You can state your case
about which one is better
than the other.
- ( high-pitched chime )
- That's the sound
that whenever
Sonic picks up a ring,
you make that sound.
Now, if you go to,
like, a gas station,
you hear them
open the register--
it's that sound.
- ( high-pitched chime )
- That little chime
gives me such joy.
I'm glad your joy comes
from a gas station.
- ( ring )
- Fantastic.
- Just a beautiful-- isn't it?
- Simple as that.
So that was when the game
first starts up,
the Nintendo logo comes down.
You can hear the difference
between the tinniness
of the Sega Genesis
compared to
the robust flavors
you get from
a Super Nintendo.
- ( chime )
- ( high-pitched chime )
The sound chip
for the Super Nintendo
was designed by Sony.
The Genesis,
I think they just got
off the rack parts.
Yeah, they just walked
into a drugstore
- and picked up
what they could find...
- Pretty much.
- ...put it in their console.
( music playing )
All right,
so let's start with Sonic.
If you could take
a step forward.
Sonic's cool.
He's fast.
He's got this cool spiky hair.
I mean, check out
that spiky hair.
I wish I had hair like that.
He's a freedom fighter.
He fights against--
Dr. Robotnik
is testing on animals.
Sonic says no to that.
Sonic just looks like
your white friend with dreads.
Let's have Mario step up.
Let's look at
a real American hero.
( music playing )
Mario is a hard worker,
he's a plumber--
one of the hardest,
most respectable jobs.
And he works with his brother,
so he's a family man.
He's a drug addict.
He's always doing mushrooms.
- That's not--
- He also takes prescription
pills. Dr. Mario.
- He's not a doctor.
He's saying he's a doctor.
- He's not taking the pills.
He gives you a lot
of medicine where they
counteract each other.
Oh, yeah,
mixing prescriptions.
That's great.
( music playing )
So, at the end of the day,
there's a lot to like
about both of these.
Clearly some pros
and cons to each.
So, between
these two for me...
...just because I'm that guy,
I would actually probably lean
towards me being
a Sega Genesis gamer.
Mainly because I feel
like I would want
high-definition graphics,
and, of course,
it's matte black.
So, my winner
is Sega Genesis.
( music playing )